on va juste faire dans le concret on va
juste faire dans le concret ça va
prendre une minute légumes secs plus 14
% légumes conserve plus 15% légumes
frais puissent 34 % les œufs 15 % le
beurre et la crème fraîche 17 % le
papier toilette 18 % l'huile de
tournesol 20 % les pâtes 21 % la viande
surgelée 29 % la viande de poulet 100 %
2 € le litre de gasoil les factures
d'énergie qui explose voilà c'est quoi
aujourd'hui un gilet jaune quelqu'un qui
ne peut pas joindre les deux bouts
encore plus qu'hier
est-ce que ça c'est du concret parce que
je pense que c'est tout à fait
à la maison la colère est toujours
présente faut juste qu'à un moment donné
le plateau comprenne on s'est fait crevé
des cieux c'est à dire que pour des
délits d'opinion parce qu'il y a une
célèbre pub sur une autre chaîne qui dit
pour délit d'opinion parce que
aujourd'hui dans une démocratie qui
s'appelle la France on s'est fait crever
des yeux parce qu'on a juste dit on en a
marre de raquer et de pas pouvoir
prendre les deux groupes voilà j'en ai
pris juste une minute
à ses citoyens envoient la police pour
apporter des réponses militaires merci
des armes de guerre merci Jérôme merci
Jérôme merci Jérôme merci Jérôme je
t'embrasse voilà je voulais intervenir
Gilles mais quand on regarde une carte
de France on voit qu'à Tarbes et encore
le mouvement à Montauban il y a encore
des gilets jaunes je voyais ça et là on
a l'impression que vous et je comprends
tout à fait au nom de la répression vous
avez souffert dans votre cher je
comprends Jérôme aussi on a l'impression
que du coup vous le voulez pas rallumer
le mouvement alors que le constat c'est
que tout explose ma question elle est
simple c'est est-ce qu'en janvier là
quand les factures effectivement
d'électricité vont arriver et ce qu'en
janvier vous pensez que le mouvement des
gilets jaunes va repartir et est-ce que
vous allez vous impulser alors focaliser
sur les gilets jaunes de façon ça va
être les gens en général parce que là
c'est plus du tout possible
ce qui a fait que il y avait pas assez
de gens dans les c'est justement parce
que on a stigmatisé les gilets jaunes en
disant si vous sortez vous allez sortir
avec des casseurs dans la rue des
antisémites des fachos des racistes et
j'en passe la liste elle est il manquait
plus que violeur parce que mais bon la
liste elle est longue
moi je dis à toutes les personnes qui se
sentent concernées parce qu'il est en
train de se passer c'est à dire à peu
près
au minimum 11 millions de personnes
c'est quand même pas mal mais je pense
qu'il y en a beaucoup plus parce qu'il y
a une classe médiane qui est en train de
prendre cher
je leur dis arrêtez de vous poser la
question de savoir avec qui vous allez
sortir dans la rue si vous devez sortir
dans la rue arrêtez de vous poser la
question de savoir avec qui vous allez
lutter si c'est pour l'intérêt collectif
parce que justement le pouvoir
médiatique a joué sur les divisions
d'opinions pour que et divertissement
pour que les gens se posent pas les
bonnes questions j'avais j'étais quand
j'étais passé ici j'avais dit une phrase
c'était
si vous devez vous poser une seule
question c'est quelle est ma place
là-dedans imaginez-vous dans une
fourmilière c'est pas participer à un
système si le si du jour au lendemain la
fourmilière elle doit se casser la
gueule le système va faire tout pour se
sauver le culu mais vous en tant que
fourmi quel est votre place là-dedans et
je vous regarde tout ça ici derrière la
caméra tous ceux qui sont sur plateau on
a plus ou moins des vies différentes
même grandement des vies différentes on
a tous des moyens financiers différents
mais demain si ça explose je pense pas
que c'est un billet de banque ou une
carte bleue qui va vous sauver je pense
pas que c'est une position dans la
société non plus qui va vous sauver